[Music]
it's one thing to make a movie that is
sort of similar to another one but it's
quite another to rip it off and make a
film that basically copies the other
stay tuned to the end when we'll show
you how one studio lifted Disney's
retelling of a classic fairy tale if
this is your first time visiting the
things then hit the subscribe button and
give this video a like today we're going
to show you ten animated movies that
copy Disney tangled up something that
Disney has pretty much made its own over
the years our animated adaptations of
classic children's stories however for
many years one famous fairy tale was
notable by its absence in Disney's
Cannon and that story was Rapunzel
however that all changed when in 2010
Disney came up with tangled costing a
record 260 million dollars it was a
massive hit but like all hits it
inspired imitators perhaps the most
notable imitator came in the shape of
tangled up by British studio bright
spark now we realize that as a classic
children's story anyone could have made
a movie based on Rapunzel however the
fact that bright spark did it not long
after Disney did theirs and then it had
a very similar title probably should
have rung alarm bells in fact you just
had to watch through the credits of
tangled up to notice something was a bit
amiss you see if you are observant
enough you would have noticed that there
the movie was called Britannica's fairy
tales from around the world it had been
repackaged to cash in on the tangled
phenomenon and people who had bought
tangled up on DVD by mistake were quick
to complain saying that tangled up was
poorly animated and not worth watching
so weak as it pays to pay attention to
what DVD it is that you're buying wings
one of the most successful movie
animation franchises of the 21st century
has been the cars films the tales of
Lightning McQueen Chick Hicks and strip
that King weathers have generated three
films a video game and millions of fans
since the first movie came out in 2006
it was yet another runaway success for
Disney's Pixar Animation Studios and
everyone wanted a piece of the action
that led Disney themselves coming out
with planes although some people thought
that planes was nothing more than a
cash-in on cars massive success Disney
actually made sure that their film
didn't contain elements that were too
close to Pixar's movies
however because
was a massive success that meant that it
too would inspire imitators and perhaps
these imitators were not quite as
thorough in avoiding utilizing the
sources material as Disney had been this
meant that shortly afterward of plans
set out we were hit with wings this is a
Russian movie that looks sounds and
feels a lot like both plans and cars it
is we think kind of shameless but there
is a bit of a difference and that's that
it doesn't quite work reviews for wings
were at best lukewarm with concerns
about relatively weak animation and the
derivative plot so take our advice here
you're better off sticking with planes
and cars Snow Queen the great Danish
writer Hans Christian Andersen is
responsible for a range of stories that
have passed into history and been turned
into Disney classics because not only
was the 1992 film The Little Mermaid
based on Anderson's work but also frozen
was inspired by The Snow Queen however
what frozen did was to take the story
and make a Disney zone however other
Studios saw just how massive frozen was
and decided to do something of their own
one such example came from Russian
studio in lay film they also did their
adaptation of the Hans Christian
Andersen classic and they almost kept
with the original title by calling it
Snow Queen however one big difference
was that while frozen was a massive
success at the box office
Snow Queen actually lost money during
its original Russian run and while it
wasn't panned by critics dagger holds
his role as ordinate role got good
notices it wasn't as warmly received as
frozen was however to give in lay film
some credit their movie was made quickly
and was actually released a little bit
before a frozen came out but there had
been word that Disney was going to do
something based on the story for a
number of years so you can see how they
were able to put out a spoiler to be
honest if you've seen frozen then you'll
be able to appreciate that it is much
better than its counterpart ratatouille
some ideas in storytelling are so
distinctive so unique that when you hear
the vaguest outline you know exactly
what it is we're talking about okay
let's try it out here's an animation
about a rat who works in a kitchen are
you thinking about ratatouille yet we
think you are in for some strange reason
you haven't seen it will tell you
briefly what it's about
it concerns a rat named Remy who has a
heightened sense of smell and dreams of
being a top chef
we won't tell you too much more but it's
really good we aren't the only ones to
think that it picked up an Academy Award
for Best Animated
so of course it ended up generating its
very own ripoff movie that was made by
Brazil's video bring Kato and it was
called ratatouille while ratatouille
garnered fans and plaudits for its smart
story and brilliant groundbreaking
animation ratatouille didn't not by a
long way telling the story of Rio de
Janeiro rat Marcel tooing and his desire
to steal food to keep his restaurant
going it was criticized a lot by pretty
much everyone to be honest its animation
isn't a patch on Pixar's classic its
story often doesn't make sense and the
voice acting is alright but nothing like
the original and the title doesn't even
make sense
the secret of Mulan when Disney released
Mulan in 1998 they really broke the mold
this was the first time that they'd
created an animated film whose basis and
story wouldn't be well known to Western
audiences if you aren't familiar with
the story of Mulan then we better let
you know what it's about and where it
comes from it's based on a series of
ancient Chinese legends about Melun a
warrior woman who takes her elderly
father's place in the army and fights
with honor so while that story would be
well known to Chinese audiences you can
see how it might be a bit of a risk for
people in the West however the film
exceeded expectations and became a huge
hit all around the world so it sure as
night follows day there were films that
were shall we say inspired by Disney's
latest blockbuster and one of those was
the secret of Mulan this film also took
the Chinese legend as its inspiration
but it did something different with it
and that was that it decided to make the
character of Mulan an insect that was
because the film was also partially
inspired by a bug's life which had
opened in theaters to great success so
even though the DVD of the secret of
Mulan came with a free CD of the
soundtrack we'd advise that you watch
the Disney original instead tiny robots
when you think back on all the classic
movies short cartoons and live-action TV
and film Disney has put out you'd
struggle to find a bad thing sure there
might be ones that you didn't like as
much but that's not the same thing the
truth is that they know who the target
audience is for everything they do and
they hits a target every single time in
the world of mock Busters there's one
particular studio that sort of works as
the knockoff Disney and that's Brazil's
video Brancato
they seem to be the masters of putting
their own low-budget twist on whatever
smash hit Disney come up with back into
and eight Disney released wall-e this
was a wonderful charming and touching
tale of a robot on a mission to clean up
the earth it won the Academy Award for
Best Animated Film and it was listed as
the best film of the naughties by the
prestigious Time magazine but it
inspired bring Kato to make their own
version saying as the character of
wall-e was a tiny robot they decided the
film would be called robos interest
which when translated into English is
tiny robots well of course it is you've
now learned a little bit of Portuguese
which means you've probably got more out
of watching this than you would watching
that film Chiara the brave brave was yet
another brilliant film from Disney that
did really well at the box office the
story of Scottish princess Marita
touched the hearts of millions of people
worldwide who watched it it also entered
into the heart of people looking to use
it as an inspiration for their own
movies one such example was Kiara the
brave a movie released by Indian studio
Shah Maru Entertainment looking at the
movie artwork featuring a feisty looking
redheaded princess you would imagine
that it would be pretty much a straight
copy of the Disney movie well this is an
example of appearances being deceiving
Princess Kiara is not the main character
in this film she's actually pretty minor
and doesn't have any bearing on the quad
it's actually about a boy superhero
called super K who protects the dream
zone from the villainous badness and dr.
ozox so you see it's quite some way away
from having the same story as brave in
fact outside of the United States it was
actually called Super K and the other
thing that made brave so popular was its
stellar cast featuring a who's who of
Scottish acting legends as well as
splendid animation again Keira the brave
didn't have those things it was heavily
panned by both critics and regular
viewers this is one of the more
shameless cash-in what's up the opening
few minutes of up are among the most
touching in the history of cinema the
story of the marriage of Carl and Ellie
Fredrickson are told in a heartbreaking
way that sets the movie up and lets us
know the characters backstories and the
film keeps going from there it was
heralded as a masterpiece and because it
was so well received it naturally
inspired other films one such example is
what's up by brazilian studio video
brink endo this movie tells the story of
an elderly man who uses balloons to lift
his house into the sky and fly away it
you've seen up then you'll know that
that is basically the premise of the
whole film however that's where the
similarities end
while Disney's Pixar studios animation
was lauded for its art and beauty what's
up looks somewhat amateurish in
comparison and the plot is rather
different too
while up sees Carl and young stowaway
Russell visit the tropical utopia of
Paradise Falls what's up
features a battle to save the world from
aliens of course they do manage to make
it to the Amazon in the film so that's
another up homage there and the main
character of what's up is a mad
scientist which is why he uses balloons
to lift his house up into the air and
fly it away bug bites and ants life any
old studio can make a movie that rips
off one film however it takes a certain
kind of genius to make a movie that
manages to rip off two blockbusters at
the same time well we've found the film
that manages to do that and that movie
is bug bites and ants life this is an
incredibly derivative film because it
catches on to the coattails of two
movies that came out in 1998 those films
were both by big named animation studios
were both hugely popular and both
featured insects they were DreamWorks
ants and the Disney Pixar movie a bug's
life although they were very different
films there was a bit of a legal dispute
between the studio's over who came up
with the idea first and whether one of
the films was ripping off the other it
didn't really matter though because both
films were absolutely brilliant they
both had cool stories fantastic
animation and some impressive voice
acting these were things that we think
were missing from bug bites and ants
life this was an incredibly derivative
film both in terms of feel and plot it
even went all the way down to the poster
where the s intent was reversed so that
it kind of looked like the letter Z
however in its own way it was even more
groundbreaking and innovative than the
film's it ripped off it was a very first
3d Mach Buster the Frog prints something
that we've noticed Disney doing and
doing well when it comes to their
adaptations of classic stories is giving
them a new twist one of the best
examples of this that we've seen in
recent years was in The Princess and the
Frog this is the very first time that
the lead character Tiana was
african-american what Disney did was
take the original fairy tale and
transport it into the middle of the 20th
century in New Orleans Louisiana
they put in some show-stopping songs and
some beautifully classic animation we
ended up with another great Disney movie
however we do need to say one thing at
this point and that is of course that
the story that the film was based on was
a classic fairy tale that means that if
someone made a movie based on it then we
would try to be generous and say that it
wasn't necessarily a ripoff however if
you look at the DVD artwork for the Frog
Prince then you might notice the
combination of an african-american
princess and the style of drawing and
say that this was a copy of the Disney
film well it is but it isn't anywhere
near as good but we wondered whether
there were any other Disney copies that
we've missed don't be shy tell us in the
comments and that's all for our ten
animated movies that copy Disney if you
liked this video don't forget to
subscribe and give it a big thumbs up
thanks for watching and see you next
time
[Music]